have a look at this let's see if we can  lighten the mood for you today if you're  a numbers nerd cherish today because  it's a mathematical  rarity it happens only once in a  lifetime it's the 22nd  of the second  2022.  it's a palindrome  22nd of the second  2022 a palindrome  but this is something else as well it's  not just a palindrome it's also an  ambigum  and it's probably a  clue one word all that isn't it um which  means that it reads the same upside down  as it does the other way up and  it also reads the same if you see it in  a  mirror and it will not happen again in  your lifetime so as you know our  director amy was very impressed in that  in the last hour stephen's taken over  he's equally impressed